For some of you,
Maybe you're even wondering
if you're ready for this,
it probably seemed like this
day would never come.
for what comes next.
You have no idea what I'm capable of.
I don't fight friends because I would
I didn't know who he was.
never apologize for saving lives.
There's
only one way this kid goes back out there,
and that's on a very short leash.
don't care how old he is.
He needs to go down now.
Maybe if you train more and complained
less, we can get back to saving lives.
I'm just happy helping people.
You know, people trying to kill us
every single day,
right?
Make him pay for what he did
to your world.
Oh, true.
My against literature like that
has not happened since the Great Purge.
come on up here. Who slayed my husband?
I'm a normal human superhero.
You should have died at birth.
wish he was dead, too.
But not for your sake.
Kill first, ask questions later.
You know how you say
I could see molecules? me.
I just want to talk about where you came
from.
Great powers came from.
I can also change you around,
Move electrons from here to there.
It's crazy.
Maybe I'm a superhero.
Your powers, you must stop using.
But I can help people.
out of my way, kid.
You're.
Why can't you just be normal?
a government designed super weapon.
I'm a freaking
Oh, The name is.
cute
No, the cape is cute
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Happy Comic-Con Week continues.
They dropped a brand new Invincible Season
2 trailer.
They announced the release date.
There's even a special episode
that they're dropping tonight.
I'll do a separate video
for that tomorrow.
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes first.
Big news is that season
two will drop November 3rd,
but they're only dropping
the first four episodes.
They'll air them back to back
week to week.
then they'll take a little break.
Then they'll air the second
four episodes and Season three
will premiere around this time next year.
Like they want to cut the gap down
so there's not like a couple of years
between season two and season three
they haven't renewed the show for season
four yet.
But like the show would continue to season
for season five,
it would also probably be eight episodes
per season for those future seasons.
Do there's a bunch of big villains
that they'll debut.
They announced
a whole bunch of cast members,
even though there isn't a ton of footage
of those brand new cast members,
like there's
a ton of really important people
you spotted, particularly
Peter Cohen is Thaddeus.
I'll explain that during the video to.
but at the beginning of the season,
it's all about dealing with
the aftermath of what happened
after his father left the planet
at the end of season one.
pretty much everybody,
including the immortal who starts to fight
him look at him
is kind of sus and he's trying to prove to
everyone that he wants to be a superhero
and help the planet.
the next real big villains, though, that
they'll be introducing are Angstrom levy.
He's like the overarching villain
of the next big arc.
But then you have people
like the champion Anissa,
and then eventually we might get a teaser
for thragg like the end of the season
he doesn't really become a big character
until much later in the story.
but at the beginning of the trailer,
there's a bit of a joke here
you probably spotted is Mark's
high school graduation ceremony
in his principal speaking.
But his high school is named Reginald
VELJOHNSON Johnson,
and it's played by real life
Reginald Bell Johnson.
they even modeled the character
after him in real life.
You probably remember him from Family
Matters or from the die Hard movies.
I just love in this fictional universe
of Invincible that Reginald Bell Johnson,
instead of being an actor,
became a high school principal
and got the high school named after him.
his speech is generally meant
to be a metaphor
for everything that Mark is going through
at the beginning of the season,
taking the next step, winning everyone
over, facing all these challenges,
all these other villains that wind up
popping up,
including the very big villains,
which they don't include in the trailer.
Like most of the big villains,
they don't put in the trailer.
you notice
while he's giving the speech, though,
they intercut with him going on missions.
He's missing from the ceremony
because he's on those missions.
Like all of his friends are sitting here
next to him
where he would normally be sitting.
the big threads from the end of season
one that they tease
were the Muellers
getting re-arrested and locked back up.
The guy in the cast on his arm
was the same guard who they wrecked
when they escaped the flagstones
plotting to attack Earth again.
they were the aliens using the time
dilation device from another dimension.
Omni-Man had traveled to their home world
in obliterated it
in the span of a couple of weeks,
it was probably one of the best sequences
during the series.
but the idea was because of the time
dilation effect,
it seemed like he was only gone
for a little while,
even though he came back
with all that extra facial hair
then there was Doc Seismic
from episode three who had come back
controlling a bunch of the Magma golems
preparing to attack again.
Titan had taken over
as the new boss of the city
and they got rid of his old boss Battle
beast attacking again in outer space.
Then there was the threat of Cecil
inspecting the upgraded reanimation drones
like they're the Terminators.
Basically.
They just keep iterating,
trying to make them more and more powerful
as the last resort
against the viltrumites
when they eventually show up again.
end they will, but not till like,
Champion shows up and Nyssa shows up.
We see him fighting the immortal
who wants him
locked up
and is also trying to help train them.
So it seems like he could go 5050
either way on him.
Like, we'll lock him up.
Don't let him out again or will train
to actually be a superhero and help us.
the connection to Ross
Mark Hand is through The Walking Dead
because Robert Kirkman
created The Walking Dead.
He was on The Walking Dead TV show,
but also in real life,
you probably remember Ross
Marquand took over as the voice of Red
Skull in a couple of other characters
in the MCU.
he's also the Voice of Ultron.
Ultron is supposed to be coming back
during the Armor Wars movie.
that's Walton
Goggins as Cecil talking about
letting Invincible going on missions again
for the Global Defense Agency,
but putting him on a short leash
since it's still early days
after the events of season one
when he's talking about it,
he fights the Muller twins again,
they're supposed to be working with
Engstrom Lee be helping him
construct his Multiversal device.
this is Corey.
Peyton is Black Samson
yelling about taking Invincible down
Then we get a montage of characters
returning from season one.
Like, pretty much everybody who survived
season one is coming back.
in probably the last scene.
And it's a really big one, too.
Really big reveal is Peter Cohen.
Optimus
Prime himself is the voice of Thaddeus.
so the idea is that
Thaddeus is a huge character
in the history of the invincible universe.
He's like an O.G.
viltrumites
that goes back to the original war
that cleansed their people
of all their weaknesses.
And when he's talking about like
I haven't seen this kind of destruction
since the last Great War,
remember built from ice
just gets stronger as they get older.
So theoretically they could live forever,
which is why he's so old.
But what wound up happening
is that when their race started,
their internal civil war
to make themselves stronger,
they started conquering
the rest of the universe.
Eventually he saw that is a great evil.
He saw their people as evil
and rebelled against them.
in the aftermath of their people's
supremacy, he became the first rebel
against their people.
The first bill tried to go against
the united bill to my people.
during episode eight.
Alan the Alien explains to Invincible
what the Coalition of Planets is basically
an anti bill tramite coalition of planets
that want to get rid of them
and stop them from conquering
the universe.
Thaddeus was actually a founding member
of the Coalition of Planets.
They briefly teased the Scourge virus
during the events of season one,
when Omni-Man is talking
about the history of their race
the scourge, was a virus that killed off
most of their race.
Some of them survived
like a very, very small number,
which is why they changed their conquering
tactics during the events of season
one, Omni-Man explained
that they would basically send one
to a planet where he would create a child.
That child would be have those right,
and then he would use that child
to take over the planet.
that was his original intention for Mark,
the invincible character
that they would conquer the planet
for built from before the scourge virus,
when there were a ton of viltrumites,
they would send in traditional forces
like a whole bunch of village
mice would go into a planet.
Then try and conquer it
the old fashioned way.
The new way was just because their numbers
were so scarce,
like they needed them to go out and create
a whole bunch more half viltrumite.
but the whole idea is that Thaddeus
actually created the scourge virus.
So who better to try and get rid of the
viltrumites, then a viltrumite himself?
that is omni-man coming back
during season two.
I love the way the in the trailer too.
You should have died at birth.
That's such an omni-man thing
to say to your child.
meaning that invincible
will reunite with him on another planet.
one of the big things
in the aftermath of season one
is that Omni-Man refused to kill his son
Invincible and left the plan.
But because Thragg ordered him
to take over a planet, he had to go find
another planet to take over.
So he just went
and did the exact same thing.
Have another child on different planet.
so basically
Mark winds up getting another half brother
from a different race of aliens
And even though the series in general
follows Mark Grayson, Invincible Omni-Man
continues to be a very important character
throughout the entire run of the comics.
and because Thaddeus was around
during the original Vulture might worry
so long lived.
He remembers everything about that race.
He becomes a big source of information
for both Omni-Man and for Mark.
there are a lot of secrets
about the history of their people,
a lot of intrigue,
a lot of Game of Thrones,
the type of stuff that they get into.
I don't wanna get into too many spoilers
during this video,
but all the comics are out there right now
like the entire run of the comics
started and finished a long time ago.
So you can actually go read that
right now.
they didn't see the events of the series
in general like season two and beyond will
be a little bit different from the comics,
but pretty close to the comic book story
They also just tease that Omni-Man
as well as Homelander from the Boys
and Peacemaker are showing up in
Mortal Kombat, one as playable characters.
not really sure what Peacemaker
is going to do in a situation like that.
Like you have a couple of gods
and there just like a normal character
with a bunch of guns.
if he spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that he didn't talk about,
or you have any big questions about things
in the trailer that I didn't address,
just write them below in the comments
tomorrow, the probably some more trailers,
maybe a Loki Season 2 trailer,
probably a couple of other
really big announcements.
So I'll try to do videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
And click here
for all my Comic-Con trailer videos.
Click here for that Secret Invasion
Episode six finale video.
Do Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!